a major escalation in the war on Ukraine
Vladimir Putin illegally declared around
40 000 square miles of Eastern and
Southern Ukraine as part of Russia
experts say it is the largest land grab
since World War II the U.S and allies
responded by slapping a new round of
sanctions on Russian government
officials and their families here is
President Biden
Putin's actions are a sign he's
struggling the United States is never
going to recognize this and quite
frankly the world's not going to
recognize it either he can't seize his
neighbor's territory
and get away with it as simple as that
America is fully prepared with our NATO
allies to defend every single inch of
NATO territory
perhaps more concerning during Putin's
unhinged speech he accused the U.S of
creating a quote precedent for using
nuclear weapons by bombing Japan fears
of nuclear war have grown since Putin
said last week he was not bluffing when
it comes to using nukes to defend his
territory
Dana I want to come to you okay first on
this it feels
like more than just an escalation like
we use that term all the time but this
is really a departure what you would say
is you'd call it a step change I believe
like not just an escalation so
um a couple of things I was able to talk
to some folks that I trust on this and
they think that this is the most
dangerous part of the situation that
we've been in because uh when Putin has
painted himself into a corner he has
very few friends uh his country is
unhappy the the people are unhappy with
the call up they've had up to perhaps as
many as 300 000 men try to leave Russia
some of the Russian men have broken
their own bones in order to avoid having
to go and fight and they are reporting
from Ukraine that they have been ordered
to kill civilians they don't want to do
it their heart's not in it the
ukrainian's heart is in it and so now
you have a situation where President
Putin we don't know who would take over
if there was to be someone else like the
devil you know is sometimes better than
the one that you don't but I also
believe that President Biden for he's
being as strong as he possibly can there
I suppose but I I have long thought that
you have to ask is Europe going to save
itself
is Europe willing
to save itself and we can be there as
well and Biden can say that but who is
going who is the face of this fight for
the Europeans and who who will step up
and who will that be they have a lot of
economic problems that they're dealing
with they're looking at a huge energy
crisis this year and they also are timid
some of them are timid and actually
getting the commitments of the weapons
uh to the ukrainians oh point to Germany
in particular so I think that one of the
things that Biden can do at least behind
the scenes he's he needs to press the
Europeans to be more willing to step up
and be the face of this there so that
Putin doesn't think this is just a war
with the United States this is a war
that he chose and that the ukrainians
decided to fight back you know they got
a choice too and we're in this situation
because the ukrainians have done very
well but at this moment we are probably
in a more dangerous Zone than we've ever
been since February
Jesse what do you think of that and also
the fact that this morning president
zielinski signed the paperwork to Fast
Track their application to Nato that'll
get rejected but I spoke to people too
and they're saying the same thing that
Dana's sources are saying Putin's only
speaking to about six people I'm told
and he demands that they lie to him so
he's not getting an accurate picture of
what's happening on the battlefield and
there is no way that we're going to
settle on Vladimir Putin's terms he has
killed
a quarter million civilians
he is he is kidnapped about a million
ukrainians
you think he's just gonna like say all
right let's negotiate we're gonna keep
the East and uh we'll just use Ukraine
as a buffer U.S policy and European
policy towards Russia right now is the
complete and total Destruction of Russia
they are going to with the Ukrainian so
they are going to expel all Russian
forces from Ukraine they will demand
repayment to rebuild everything in
Ukraine there will be a war crimes
tribunal to hold all of these people
accountable for these for the massive
civilians that they've slaughtered
you're not just going to invade this
country commit atrocities and then walk
away after destroying the entire
International Supply Chain destroying
the energy markets in Europe you got to
be kidding me so I mean this is the guy
is he is he is going to lose this and
it's not looking good
will he use nukes well certainly there's
the growing possibility and potential of
an escalation or a at the very least a
tactical Nuclear Strike to Dana's point
we we as I say the West we Europe and
the United States
um we have not starved Putin of money or
Manpower uh Europe can help out by
opening up the countries to all of the
Russians and Russian men who are trying
to get away from Vladimir Putin um take
them in draft Dodgers make them refugees
open their doors there are a lot of
countries who are refusing to do that or
dragging their dragging their feet on
that but also we haven't done really
anything to bankrupt Putin's regime the
we're we're not willing the politicians
aren't willing to risk a recession but a
nuclear conflict somehow is a risk worth
taking that's where we are we we need to
up we need to drive down the price of
natural gas and oil and that does mean
more Supply but it also means crushing
and crippling demand like it happened
during covet we have not done that we
are actually doing the exact opposite to
drive up demand for fuel California is
getting ready to send checks to half the
people in the state oh because of the
high gas prices you need more money no
that doesn't hurt demand and then over
in Europe just to name one Britain is
capping household energy bills so you
can use as much energy as you want
anything in excess of the cap we're just
going to send money to Vladimir Putin
that is irretrievably moronical
Greg I was confused when uh President
Biden said it was NATO territory because
they're not I yeah it's because
it's because NATO countries with the war
yeah that's yeah that's doesn't make
sense to me I you know
um
I it's a sham annexation on nobody's
taking it seriously I never heard of
these places 10 months ago I do know
that our country right now we're going
through some very very uh serious times
we just talked about the crime we have
inflation our economy is in this Cooper
and it it you know it's like all that's
changing with this is that we just keep
sending billions and billions and
billions of dollars there and all we're
doing is we're not affecting the outcome
we're affecting the duration so the
thing just all we're doing is making it
longer but we have a sense that we know
how it's going to end there is no way
Putin is going to give in and he doesn't
care about his people and speaking of
people there's a generation gap there
half the people are pro-putin I mean
more than half the people of pro Putin
older Generations like him because he's
been around maybe they've been
brainwashed the younger people they're
leaving so he I mean he's he I don't
think he has any any reason to worry so
we're at this point where I feel like
Republicans and the Democrats are in
agreement in terms of War but not in
terms of peace and this is where my
crazy idea is that it would be really
nice to see somebody like Trump and
Obama together doing something like a
together and and and and trying to help
negotiate some kind of Peace it's
impossible it's absurd it's a crazy idea
but it's not as crazy as thinking you
know men can get pregnant so I if you
want to laugh at if you want to laugh at
the idea of like two presidents
diametrically opposed coming together
Trump calling him if Obama doesn't call
him back that's not a good sign if they
call and they go look you know maybe we
can talk you know I I could talk to
Putin you could talk to the zelinski we
do it that's if you just think that's
crazy
then you're what ideas do you so yeah
forget what I said about your birth
certificate I'll apologize for spying on
your campaign we'll fly to Europe and do
it exactly but you hey every single cop
buddy film they always win at the end
even when they hate each other Lethal
Weapon 48 Hours
um no way they're gonna ride in the same
car though the point is the point is
nobody is talking about a negotiation
nobody's talking about off-ramps and I
think that I think there might be an
off-ramp with with you know when the
oligarchs see their money truly
threatened and they're just and they're
getting killed oligarchs are getting
killed there might be an exit strategy
that they create for Putin the way they
did with Yeltsin right where you you say
look your guarantees you get to keep all
your money we're not going to kill your
secretary of defense we're not going to
kill anybody but you're going to get to
go and then they trans so they so and
then but they have to make it look like
you want something maybe the Don bass
you know maybe that's what they give
them and then then they can but they're
not giving them anything I know I know I
know and that's why we're gonna keep
giving them billions and the outcome
will be the same but destroyed country
Ukraine it is interesting though because
it seems like zelinski is the one who's
the most hardened the negotiation
because he said I'm never going to do it
with him exactly where he was for a
negotiations
but a lot of people have died it wasn't
for that so remember that too
we
solved nothing no we did it was good hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else